THAT'S THE FALCON
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AS WE APPROACH ELECTION DAY,
HERE IS ONE THING THAT HAS
BECOME PATENTLY OBVIOUS.
DEMOCRATS ARE UNINTERESTED IN
THE THINGS AMERICANS CARE ABOUT
MOST.
THEIR PROSPERITY AND THEIR
SAFETY.
INSTEAD OF POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS,
DEMOCRATS POISON AMERICAN
DISCOURSE WITH CONSTANT
ATOMIZATION
DEMONIZATION.
IN THE KAVANAUGH SAGA, WE SAW
THEY ARE MASTERS OF PRODUCING
CHOREOGRAPHED OUTRAGE.
AFTER THAT BACKFIRED, DEMOCRATS
STARTED TO PANIC.
ALTHOUGH STILL FAVORED TO TAKE
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTED, THINGS
BEGAN TO SHIFT SOMEWHAT AFTER
THE KAVANAUGH DUST SETTLED.
STORIES SUDDENLY BEGAN TO POP UP
THAT PELOSI, SCHUMER, AND
COMPANY, WOULD CONCERN THAT
LATINO VOTERS WERE
INSUFFICIENTLY ENTHUSIASTIC IN
THE MIDTERM.
WHICH COULD DOOM DEMOCRATS
CHANCES TO TAKE THE HOUSE.
THEN, LIKE MAGIC, A FEW DAYS
LATER A STORY APPEARED OUT OF
NOWHERE ABOUT ANOTHER CARAVAN OF
CENTRAL AMERICANS HEADING FROM
HONDURAS.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Laura: A FORMER HONDURAN
LEFT-WING POLITICIAN EVEN JOINED
THE CARAVAN FOR A TIME BEFORE HE
WAS ARRESTED.
WHAT STARTED AS A GROUP OF 1600
SOON BECAME 2,000.
AND THEN 4,000.
APPARENTLY GROWING.
MEANWHILE, CRUSADING REPORTERS
ARE FEEDING THE NARRATIVE THAT
ANYONE OPPOSED TO WELCOMING
THESE CARAVAN OR
ERS ARE CRUEL,
ROTTEN PEOPLE.
>> WHAT IS THE G.O.P. STRATEGY?
WE SEE IT AT THIS POINT IS TO
PUSH FEAR AND LOATHING.
IF YOU DON'T VOTE, THE SCARY
PEOPLE FROM THE SOUTH ARE COMING
FOR YOU.
>> YOU SEE THAT PICTURE?
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
THINK ALL IMMIGRANTS LOOK LIKE.
PEOPLE LAYING ON THE FLOOR
SPLAYED OUT, NOT AS CIVILIZED AS
YOU CAN BE DIFFERENT FROM.
>> Laura: THE MEDIAS OVER THE
TOP SLURS AGAINST THOSE OF US
WHO BELIEVE THE SYSTEM MUST
CHANGE IN OUR BORDER HAS TO BE
PROTECTED, IT SPEAKS VOLUMES
ABOUT THEIR BIAS AND THE REAL
MOTIVATION.
OF COURSE, WHICH IS TO HELP
DEMOCRATS LIKE PRESIDENTIAL
HOPEFUL JULIO AND CASTRO
>> THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO
FEARMONGERING AROUND
IMMIGRATION.
ONE OF THE WORST THINGS TO
HAPPEN THESE LAST 18 MONTHS IS
BASICALLY STATE-SPONSORED CHILD
ABUSE OF YOUNG KIDS AT THE
BORDER.
THIS EXAMPLE TODAY OF WHAT HE
SAID WAS "A CARAVAN"...
YOU KNOW, HE'S PICKING THAT AND
TRYING TO MAKE AN ISSUE OF IT TO
GIN UP HIS BASE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN
SEE THROUGH THAT.
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THROUGH?
DEMOCRATS' 40 COMPASSION
POLITICALLY TIME IN A DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO TURN THAT LATINO
VOTERS WHO THEMSELVES SEEING THE
WONDERS OF THE TRUMP ECONOMY,
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE
BEST ECONOMY IN DECADES.
CASTRO WAS THE MAYOR OF
SAN ANTONIO AND HIS BROTHER
REPRESENTS AN ATTORNEY OR
CONGRESS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANY OF THEM ON
TELEVISION STANDING FOR THOSE
WHO BRUTALLY ALIENS, BRUTALLY,
BRUTALLY HURT BY RAPE, SPOUSAL
ABUSE, CHILD ABUSE, AND EVEN
MURDER.
>> CRIME SCENE TAPE STILL
OUTSIDE THIS APARTMENT ON JONES
MUSBURGER ROAD, JUST YESTERDAY
WHERE FIREFIGHTERS FOUND A BADLY
BURNED BODY.
POLICE ARRESTED AND CHARGED
ERNESTO GARCIA WITH MURDER,
ARSON, ABUSE OF A COURSE.
SAN ANTONIO HAS LEARNED U.S.
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT IS A PART OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: I.C.E. WAS
APPARENTLY INVOLVED IN THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE STORY, EVEN
BEFORE THE GRUESOME MURDER.
BACK IN 2017, GARCIA WAS
ARRESTED FOR DWI AND THE
MISDEMEANOR CRIMINAL MISCHIEF
AFTER HE REPORTEDLY RAMMED HIS
TRUCK INTO THE CAR OF AN
EX-GIRLFRIEND AND HER FAMILY
MEMBER.
HE GOT AN IMMIGRATION JUDGE,
THOUGH, TO GIVE HIM A VOLUNTARY
DEPARTURE ORDER.
LLOYD YOU BE SURPRISED
WOULD YOU BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THAT HE DID NOT LEAVE THE
COUNTRY VOLUNTARILY AFTER THAT
ORDER?
A FEW MONTHS LATER, HE WAS IN
I.C.E. CUSTODY A SECOND TIME.
A SECOND TIME HE WAS GIVEN A
VOLUNTARY DEPARTURE ORDER.
AND NOW, IN JUST 11 DAYS, HE
AWAITS HIS TRIAL FOR THE MURDER
OF JERRY VARGAS.
WHY AREN'T ANY OF THE DEMOCRATS
WHO RAIL AGAINST FAMILY
SEPARATION ALSO RAILING ABOUT
STORIES LIKE THIS!
55 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FOUND
STUFFED IN A TRUCK READY TO BE
SHIPPED ACROSS UNITED STATES AND
UNDOUBTEDLY TO UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS.
OUR OPEN BORDERS, AS WELL AS OUR
IMMIGRATION AND ASYLUM
LOOPHOLES, ARE ENRICHING THE
CARTELS, THEY ARE ENDANGERING
MIGRANTS, AND THEY ARE ALSO
MAKING LIFE WORSE FOR MOST
AMERICANS BEYOND THE SUPER RICH
WHO LIVE IN A PROTECTIVE BUBBLE.
HOW CAN WE CONTINUE WITH THIS
AND LIVE AS A COUNTRY?
NOT ALL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMMIT VIOLENT CRIME AND MANY
ARE GOOD, HARDWORKING PEOPLE.
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY THE POINT.
NO AMERICAN SHOULD SUFFER OR BE
BRUTALIZED IN ORDER TO FULFILL
THE DEMOCRATS' FANTASY OF A
BORDERLESS SOCIETY.
NO AMERICAN WORKERS AND SEE THEY
ARE WAGES GO DOWN BECAUSE OF THE
LIMO GREAT AMERICANS WHO JUST
ARRIVED IN THE U.S. WHO IS
WILLING TO WORK FOR 40% LESS.
AND DONALD TRUMP, WE FINALLY
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO WANTS TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM.
NOT JUST PASS IT ONTO THE NEXT
PRESIDENT THE WAY OBAMA DID.
YOU DON'T BUY FOR A MOMENT WHAT
THE LEFT IS SELLING YOU.
DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES USING
THIS AND THAT STOKING FALSE FEAR
AMONG THE LATINO PLURALISTS TO
TRY TO FILL CONGRESS.
AGAIN, NO IDEAS, JUST MORE
EMOTIONAL MANIPULATION.
WE WELCOME AND WE TREASURE THE
HISPANIC IMMIGRANTS OF THIS
COUNTRY WHO CAME HERE THE LEGAL
WAY, LIKE TIA FROM VENEZUELA WHO
CALLED IN TO MY RADIO SHOW
TODAY.
>> I WAS BORN IN VENEZUELA.
I AM A PROUD AMERICAN CITIZEN
NOW.
BUT I AM TERRIFIED OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
MY MOTHER WOULD'VE NEVER THOUGHT
IN VENEZUELA 30 YEARS LATER WAS
GOING TO BE A SOCIALIST COUNTRY.
AND 5-8 YEARS AFTER THAT WAS
GOING TO DESCEND INTO A
DICTATORSHIP.
ONCE THEY GET IN, THEY CHANGE
THE CONSTITUTION, THEY AREN'T
EVEN WAITING.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
CONSTITUTION AND THERE GOES OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THERE GOES OUR
I GET A LOT OF CALLS IN THE
RADIO, LEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
RANGE.
WE ALL KNOW THE NEGATIVE -- LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN CALIFORNIA'S
RAMPANT HOMELESSNESS, FILTHY
STREETS, POLLUTING WELFARE
PROGRAMS FOR THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC
DEMOCRAT SUPER MAJORITY AS OF
LOOKING LIKE.
THE PRESIDENT IS STANDING UP FOR
YOU.
HE WANTS THIS TO STOP.
THIS MORNING, HE TWEETED, "WE
SPEND BILLIONS ENFORCING OTHER
COUNTRIES' BORDERS AS OUR OWN
HAS BECOME A JOKE.
OUR LAWS IGNORED AND OUR
GENERATION AND COMPASSION
EXPLOITED" HERE WE HAVE ALMOST
NO CONTROL OF THEIR POPULATIONS,
I ASKED MEXICO THE STOP IS ON
AND IF ARE THEY ARE UNABLE TO DO
SO, I WILL CALL UP THE U.S.
MILITARY AND CLOSE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT HIS TWEETS SAID.
THE DEMOCRATS TALK TAKING THE
HOUSE WILL ENSURE THAT THIS
CARAVAN OF 4,000 EVENTUALLY
BECOMES A SLOW 4 MILLION PLUS
BEFORE YOU KNOW IT.
THIS CANNOT HAPPEN.
BUT AS WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT,
IF YOU ARE STILL ON THE FENCE
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO IN
THE MIDTERM ELECTION, JUST THINK
FOR A MOMENT ABOUT WHO IS IN
LINE TO CHAIR THE IMPORTANT
COMMITTEES WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE ISSUES, LIKE HOMELAND
SECURITY AND THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
THE HOUSE.
BENNIE THOMPSON FROM MISSISSIPPI
WOULD TAKE HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> YOU WOULD THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOMELAND SECURITY
PROBLEM FACING THE NATION IS A
HANDFUL OF CENTRAL AMERICANS
MOVING THROUGH MEXICO.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE IT SO.
BETTER TO DISTRACT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FROM THE REAL ISSUES
FACING -- PERHAPS FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN PROBLEMS TOO.
>> Laura: JERRY METTLER WITH
OVER TWO JUDICIARY WHICH
INCLUDES IMMIGRATION AND BORDER
SECURITY.
HE'S FAR MORE INTERESTED IN
INVESTIGATING JUST A KAVANAUGH
THEN SOLVING OUR BORDER PROBLEM.
COME ON.
HISPANIC AMERICANS ARE SMART
ENOUGH TO SPOT A CON WHEN THEY
SEE ONE.
I SAY IT'S TIME TO WALK AWAY
FROM THE DEMOCRATS' CYNICAL GAME
OF IDENTITY POLITICS AND